[Music]
attention incoming business you are in
violation of Elysium airspace 10,000
kilometers and closing
hi I'm Mike Seymour from FX guide.com
for Wired while there's been a trend to
more and more computer graphics effects
in films directors and frankly speaking
audiences have been looking for more
realism so there's a push to get back to
doing as much as possible in camera as
much as possible on set we've seen this
particular at work in the new film
Elysium director Neill Blomkamp was
nearly obsessed with getting as much in
camera as possible which meant models
miniatures props sets and some really
hardcore locations with the opening half
of the film set on earth the team went
to a location in Mexico to one of the
world's largest garbage dumps when real
props could be used they were when they
couldn't image engine the visual effects
company behind the film and the
directors earlier district 9 use doubles
they doubled the spaceship or the Ravens
with helicopters and they doubled the
robot droids with guys in special gray
tracking suits to allow for greater
interaction believable movement all of
whom were of course replaced later in
post-production with digital CG droids
that were controlled with over 686
individual controls
[Music]
gray suit performance on set so that
Neal can direct and edit with a
performance that's very very close to
what he's anticipating is going to be
the final result what's offer the task
of getting realism is a little harder of
course
the orbiting Elysium is enormous it's
about two kilometers wide 40 kilometers
in diameter it has a circumference of
120 5.6 kilometers so we're with the
team go for reference where could they
film down here on earth to match Elysium
nirvana
where else Malibu
I went out with Neil to Malibu and
Hollywood Hills and did a lot of
helicopter reference photography out
there and Neil actually said you look
this shot of this helicopter shot you're
flying over Malibu is exactly what I
envisioned visitor would look like when
we're flying over top of of Elysium but
we need to remove the roads we need to
remove all of the earthly structures and
just keep the mansions and then add in
maybe some landing platforms for
shuttles and so on the more complex
shots of that Elysium ring actually
contained over three trillion polygons
but you got to know Neil Blomkamp would
have still built the done thing if
you've been able to well don't forget to
subscribe if you want more behind the
scenes action I might see more for why
you